at least the greeks can laugh at
themselves and their seeming resistance
to any real economic reform
thessaloniki is greece's second largest
city a good place to get a first-hand
impression of progress so far
among the primary causes of the crisis
were certain deeply rooted customs and
habits and they've got to change
but it's not easy to find someone
willing to talk about the ordinary
everyday corruption
this man wishes to remain anonymous
i asked him where the corruption is
normally found
the only way to get a doctor to treat
you is to bribe him
if you need a permit from a government
agency you have to pay off an official
or you'll just get tangled in a jungle
of red tape
if you work in the public sector you
have to buy off somebody
and it's still that way
nothing's been done about corruption
says 37 year old nikos and without a
payoff you can't get anywhere around
here
i went to see an official recently for a
permit to open a business
he told me there were two possibilities
either i paid the regular 250 euros and
i'd get it someday
or i pay 1500 euros and i'd have it in a
week
just like that
on top of the corruption old boys
networks are paralyzing reform the
established taxi companies for example
have the business in their pockets with
no intention of opening it up to new
competitors
of course there's pressure to break the
monopoly on the taxi business so the
fares will go down
but that won't help the customers or the
city
i think more competition is pointless
we can hardly live from taxi driving as
it is
on the waterfront is the sailboat and
yacht marina
the crisis seems to have had little
effect here
at least there was no lack of money for
the yearly upkeep of these boats or
theoretically for an overhaul of the
public finances
janis jordanides is certain of that he's
a retired building contractor
he says so many well-to-do cheat on
their taxes just like they've always
done
even if the rich were to be taxed
the banks wouldn't have the capital we
need for loans to fund the recovery
besides
what good would it do to make the
wealthy responsible for solving the debt
crisis
they've already moved their money out of
the country
there's nothing to be had from them
he himself has always paid whatever
taxes he owed even on his sailboat he
says
back in the city center the burning
question is why have the abuse has been
allowed to survive these six years of
crisis economic expert demetrius mardus
of the aristotle's university gives his
view
i have the impression that our
politicians are living with the illusion
that they can have their cake and eat it
too
that they can hold on to the existing
system and its habits
only if the international bank rollers
at the imf the eu and the european
central bank
put the pressure on will anything start
to change
if not everything will stay the same
this view is shared by many greeks
experts or not
there can't be any reforms
if we have the same power elite and the
same officials nothing will change
only the amounts of the bribes have been
adjusted because of the crisis
instead of 1500
now you'd pay a thousand for example
greece in the spring of 2014 and the
crisis goes on